it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines for that we turn to
fox news contributor raymond arroyo ray
uh speaker pelosi wrapped it up there
didn't she uh in taiwan
after the biden administration
and the chinese they tried to scuttle
that trip yeah well laura say what you
want about pelosi she sticks to her guns
and she has been tireless in defending
human rights not only in china but all
over the world i only wish she had
scripted her comments a little bit more
in our earliest days of our
founding of that country
benjamin franklin presidency said
freedom
and democracy
freedom and democracy and one thing
security here
if we don't have
we can't have either
if we don't have both
well her heart was in the right place in
the right place yeah
yeah well she she met she meant those
who would give up essential liberty to
purchase a little temporary safety
deserve neither liberty nor safety she
was close what are you gonna do forgive
me it's so warm in this studio here but
i i gotta say nancy pelosi has done some
incredible things here though laura she
she did go over there there was national
security importance because of the
superconductor chips she's trying to
ensure that we have access to half of
the superconductor foundries in the
world while starting our own here in the
united states this was a smart visit
contrary to what you're hearing from
some parlance in the democratic and the
republican party
i think we all know you know what china
is now if you ever had any doubts about
what china really represents yeah i
think it you should be disabused of that
notion now especially all the liberals
where's the squad why aren't they
defending nancy pelosi's trip meanwhile
president laura was working the
president was working the phones with
his national security team you've heard
of long-term covet biden is apparently
worried about long-distance covet he's
wearing a mask in the room on the phone
nobody's there but then later he held an
abortion cabinet meeting without a mask
or possibly a clue
health care crisis is
you know
it's just it's hard for me to even
understand how they think this
last night in congress in kansas they
found out to allow them to provide
reproductive health care for women who
live in states where where where
abortions were are being banned
okay ray he didn't have a mask on
because it was a zoom
cabinet meeting there
well that that well that's not entirely
true staff was in the room with him
laura during the zoom call and he's
still covered positive watch this he's
trying to get their permission looking
right now okay
[Music]
we feel your presence mr president
it's like a seance you get the feeling
kamala loves having biden confined to
the room laura but it's clear the
platform the democratic party is going
to run on in these midterms is an
abortion in every pot we'll see how
successful that strategy is given the
polling with inflation as the number one
issue for most voters going into this
election cycle well or maybe it's just
abortion and pot and porn
and high gas prices i mean
abortion every pot abortion and pot
yeah all right ray there's a new beauty
trend i understand that the wall street
journal has identified it
it's looking fairly sweaty to me
yeah it's sweaty
are you bringing this up because it's
hot in the studio ingram look there is a
trend yeah it looks like the runway on
movie screens and
they claim that this glistening slick
look is sexy and youthful uh the article
recommends a bunch of ways to achieve
this look or you can just i guess come
into the studio or stand out in the
weather you don't have to worry about it
at all do you think this dewy look is
attractive
well it depends on whether the
the man is you know has you know good
physique i mean if it's dewy and pudgy
then that
god everyone comes in different shapes
raymond but then it might not the
glisten might not work well
i i don't think anybody really i mean
everybody kind of looks sweaty when
they're i mean i'm i'm dying in this
studio tonight ingram but most people
when they're when they're dewy when
they're sweaty i just don't think it
looks good it's kind of underrated i
think in many ways i'm just dying in
here we got to turn the arrow i think a
new fashion trend raymond
raymond i think a new fashion trend
should be buggy okay because last night
i was sworn in
last night swarming around that's a
whole new new uh scenario and then
ingram
yeah and tonight there's you know we're
we're we're doing our best that's all i
can say the locusts are approaching all
right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else